ceci est un squelette de dinosaure
de la fin du trias environ 205 210
millions d'années
alors vous montrer quelques parties ici
vous avez une vertèbre convient de
recouvrir de glu c'est pour ça qu'elle
est un peu brillante vous avez donc
l'arche moral ici les igg apophyses là
et là on va très bien le losc alors çà
et là vous avez le centrum de la
vertèbre vous avez ici
voilà que
les vertèbres caudales du dinosaure et
par là vous avez
quelques vertèbres quelques grosses
vertèbres peut-être accrocher un bassin
avec ici vous voyez une jambe qui
commencent à sortir et qu'on a déjà
commencé à plâtre est là donc on a un
squelette partiel d'un gros dinosaures
peut-être très similaire à ma sauce
ponte di luce donc un pro sauropodes ce
qu'on appelait autrefois les pros
sauropodes les les ancêtres les
sauropodomorphes non sauropodes alors ça
ce que vous voyez c'est pas la tête
c'est juste de l'eau ce qui dépasse
probablement des vertèbres mêlant bon on
a un squelette déjà par là le l'arrière
du squelette en gros qui est par là avec
l'avant du squelette qui va peut-être
partir là sous sous les déblais que vous
voyez ici
puisqu'on a de l'eau ce qui est en train
de sortir de cette région là de delà de
l'heure de la fouille donc voilà bonjour
à toutes et à tous aujourd'hui je suis
dans le dans la formation elliott donc
l'information elliott ce que vous voyez
derrière moi c'est la zone a dit n'osant
d'afrique du sud on va dire qui datent
donc de la fin du trias alors ici c'est
la lower elliott donc c'est le yacht
inférieur elliott inférieur qui est
immédiatement à la toute fin du trias
est au dessus d'elle vous avez là
elliott supérieur qui est normalement
rouge brique
la ligote supérieur on va peut-être pas
la voir on la verra pas ici là dans les
collines qui sont derrière moi
dans les collines là bas c'est ce que
vous voyez rouge brique en dessous de la
gros du gros grès jaune jaune blanc en
fonction de comment des couleurs rendent
sur la caméra je vais aller mettre un
petit peu à l'abri du vent parce que ça
doit pas être agréable au niveau du
micro
donc ici on est à la quasiment à la
frontière du avec le lesotho le mézo tôt
il est par là à seulement quelques
kilomètres
donc vous vous croisez vous croisez la
frontière là bas et donc en fouille dans
ce qu'on appelle des donga qui sont ces
systèmes de rivière temporaire à chaque
fois qu'il ya une tempête parce que ici
on est en afrique du sud on a un régime
sécheresses tempêtes
voilà il n'y a pas entre eux deux
et donc à chaque fois qu'il ya des
tempêtes et bien une très très forte
érosion qui crée c'est très très beau
d'affleurements que vous voyez là mais
ça c'est cpt2 de dinosaures et les os de
dinosaures sont très très bien préservés
et je viens de me rendre compte que
j'avais laissé mon os de dinosaures
là-haut donc j'y retourne je retourne
voir le vent donc on est en train de
fouiller la donc avec l'équipe de jonah
choinière donc c'est son terrain à lui
ce n'est pas le projet trine axes
le projet trina qui s'est passé il s'est
très bien passé tout est tout allait
comme sur des roulettes mais ça c'est
bendjé thomas et et
double james qui vont vous en parler sur
leur chaîne allez les voir si vous ne
les connaissez pas c'est en anglais mais
c'est très très très très intéressant
donc oui le ceci n'est pas le projet
trine axe c'est à une autre fouille qui
est dirigée donc par le paléontologue
jonah choiniere le professeur je lâche
one year qui est spécialiste du coût des
dinosaures des premiers dinosaures
ici vous voyez là ça c'est un os
typiques comme on en trouve ici dans la
formation elliott donc préservation
noirâtre mais la préservation peut aussi
être blanche selon l'érosion et alors là
vous voyez la préservation est tellement
bonne que du coup on voit la surface de
l'os mais on voit aussi l'intérieur de
l'os les différents tissus donc
évidemment il est couvert de glu encore
une fois donc il est brillant mais on
voit les différents tissus voilà l'os
corticale à l'extérieur est ici l'os de
la lho ce qui est à l'intérieur les deux
tissus lost médullaire
donc voilà on a vraiment de la chance
ici on trouve beaucoup beaucoup de beaux
d'ossements il ya là où je me trouve en
ce moment donc il ya un squelette ici
mais il y avait aussi un squelette là
qui a été retirée qui a été collecté
déjà et il y avait un autre squelette
juste là et là bas au pied de la colline
que vous voyez là bas il ya encore alors
pour l'instant c'est un c'est ce qu'on
appelle la bonne blague c'est à dire un
assemblage dos pas encore tout à fait
identifiables et identifiés mais mais
mais
tout vient à point à qui sait attendre
j'ai envie de dire et peut-être qu'on
aura encore un squelette là bas donc le
dinosaure dominant ici c'est ma sauce
pondi lui c'est tous et tous les trucs
qui ressemble donc les premiers
dinosaures
sauropodomorphes pas encore des
sauropodes mais déjà avec à long cou et
une petite tête et des poids pouvant
atteindre jusqu'à 12 tonnes comme le
lait douma a dit qui vient aussi
d'afrique du sud à la frontière du
lesotho
donc c'est un environnement absolument
parfait ici pour parler extinction des
dinosaures pourquoi est-ce que c'est un
environnement parfait déjà parce qu'on a
des dinosaures et puis aussi parce que
la formation elliott dans laquelle je me
trouve et bien préserve du mois
pense-t-on mais c'est en cours d'étude
il y aurait une limite
entre le trias et le jurassique là où en
fait donc donc en fait dans la formation
il ya de la formation elliott inférieure
est de la fin du trias et la formation
eliette supérieur et du début du
jurassique donc on a là l'extinction de
la fin du trias qui est l'une des
grandes cinq extinctions de masse
enregistrés dans le registre fossile est
enregistrée ici donc on est dans un
environnement tout à fait approprié pour
parler
extinction de masse des dinosaures est
justement aujourd'hui je voulais vous
parler des de l'extinction des
dinosaures et du débat qui a eu
récemment une équipe française avec en
premier auteur un français nommé
condamine
bon on suggérait en fait reçu gérer
ressuscité j'ai envie de dire l'idée
encore qu'elle était jamais réellement
morte cette idée mais ils ont remis au
goût du jour on va dire l'idée que les
dinosaures sont se sont éteints après un
long déclin des dinosaures non aviens
évidemment ce sont état après un long
déclin
sauf les oiseaux
une idée donc qui était qui était on va
dire l'idée dominante avant que
l'hypothèse alvarez soit mise sur le
plat sur le plateau à savoir l'hypothèse
de l'extinction par la météorite
alors arrêtez de regarder mon chapeau
qui est crade
je sais que vous faites une fille sage
je sais que vous êtes en train de
commenter la sur le fait que mon chapeau
soit crade et qu'il aurait pu prendre
une douche avant d'enregistrer mais
c'est à ça qu'on ressemble quand on
creuse
quand on cause réellement c'est pas
comme dans les films voilà on est
dégueulasse on est dégueulasse et encore
je me suis un peu rhabiller j'ai un trou
dans ma chemise à l'arrière donc gelé
mis dans mon pantalon voilà mon chapeau
et dégueulasse parce qu'il prend la
poussière et la sueur
faut savoir qu'ici on est on est entre
passionnés voilà vous moi l'équipe qui
est en train de fouiller on est enfant
né entre passionnés et la passion ne
connaît pas de limites et surtout pas la
crasse en parlant de passion d'ailleurs
en parlant de passion on a quand même
donc vous n'avez pas vu ou peut-être
vous avez vu dans le décor je sais pas
il ya trois voitures on était censé être
quatre voitures sauf qu'il en a une qui
s'est crashé dons qu'elle a fait elle
est parti dans le décor et a fait trois
tonneaux
donc on a ruiné une bagnole pas la
mienne c'est pas moi qui conduisais
celle là c'était une étudiante il était
à 3 dans la voiture et ils sont tous
ressortis miraculeusement indemne enfin
miraculeusement autant que faire trois
tonneaux soit un miracle évidemment mais
mais ils sont tous ressortis à 1 m ils
sont allés à l'hôpital pour un check-up
de trois heures donc ils ont ils ont
contrôlé qu'ils avaient vraiment rien
qu'ils avaient aucune conclusion ni rien
ils ont même pas un bleu il y en a une
qui a une bosse sur la tête et c'est
tout
et qu'est ce qu'ils ont fait après sable
ils ont pris une autre voiture ils sont
venus
les gars ils font trois tonneaux dans le
décor ils continuent ils disent non mais
nous on vient quand reviennent sur le
terrain donc c'est ça la passion voilà
donc
donc ça va être un peu crado c'est pas
grave comparé comparer ce qui peut vous
arriver et pourtant ça n'arrête pas la
passion bref je m'égare parlons
extinction des dinosaures donc oui il ya
eu cet article par condamine et étals
qui a donc remis au goût du jour on va
dire l'idée que les dinosaures s'était
éteint après un lent déclin idée qui a
eu tendance un peu à perdre de l'élan
après le alvarez étals et proposer leur
hypothèse que d'une extinction par la
météorite puisque évidemment un long
déclin n'est pas compatible avec une
extinction par météorite enfin si c'est
compatible mais c'est moins
spectaculaire de dire que les dinosaures
étaient déjà crevé quand ils se sont
quand ils s'en sont pris à météorite sur
la tronche on est bien d'accord donc
voila et est donc bon c'est déjà faux
voir que c'est une hypothèse qui s'était
jamais vraiment éteint éteinte puisque
cette hypothèse elle a encore fait
l'objet de d'articles en 2012 en 2010
nuit enfin bref c'est une hypothèse qui
c'est qui encore récemment
émises sur la table c'est une hypothèse
qui n'est pas du tout facile à évaluer
parce que le problème c'est que une et
comment est ce qu'on évalue une
extinction voilà comment est ce que
comment est ce que vous quand je vous
dis là bas là il ya une extinction
comment est ce que je le sais
alors celle là c'est pas l'extinction
avec laquelle je suis plus familier
l'extinction avec laquelle j'ai le plus
familier c'est celle de la famille parmi
1 puis ça tombe bien c'est la plus
évidente c'est la plus grosse
l'extinction de la fin du permien il ya
90% de ce qu'ils vivent et qui est mort
donc ça permet quand même de d'avoir une
bonne idée de ce qui se passe et bien
sur le terrain comment est ce qu'on sait
qu'il ya une extinction et ben c'est pas
si évident que ça puisque si vous venez
en afrique du sud et que vous vous
attendez à voir du coup à regarder la
roche alors pas de ce côté-là ça c'est
des alluvions si vous regarder de ce
côté là dans les informant voilà pour
garder dans les affleurements
et que vous vous attendez à voir plein
de faux cils une extinction donc rien du
tout et plein de fossiles de nouveau bah
c'est pas ça qui se passe à la limite
entre le entre le permien trias c'est
pas du tout ça qui se passe ce qui se
passe c'est que on a plein de fossiles
tout du long
donc donc déjà l'extinction on ne la
voit pas sur le terrain et c'est bien
les données de terrain à chaque fois
qu'ils sont utilisés parce que ce que
propose condamine d'antan et ses
collègues dans leur article c'est une
nouvelle méthode pour gérer pour
comprendre les données c'est un nouveau
modèle si vous voulez les utilisent
qu'un nouveau modèle sur des données qui
existe déjà et qui viennent du terrain
donc bon bah c'est un modèle qui vient
de la biologie de l'écologie ça donne un
résultat qui est pour eux un déclin
voilà et puis les gens qui avaient fait
un autre modèle avant ça il avait
utilisé grosso modo les mêmes données
peut-être un peu plus de données si je
me rappelle bien
mais bon plus vous incluez de données et
plus vous incluez les biais qui vont
avec non ça c'est pareil c'est un autre
débat aussi un ses fautes il inclure
plus de données qui sont plus biaisée au
moins de données qui sont plus propres
en cours d'aminé talent ils ont opté
pour moins de donner plus propre que le
ceux qui avaient publié je croise était
en 2018 bref et donc mais toutes ces
données de toute façon elles viennent du
terrain et comment on voit sur le
terrain qu'à une extinction de masse
c'est pas en nombre de fossiles c'est
pas comme ça que ça marche si vous avez
une belle section à travers la à travers
la limite permise trias ce que vous
voyez c'est plein de faux cils plein de
faux cils et plein de fausses il ya pas
d'interruption de fossilisation par
contre c'est la nature des fossiles qui
va être différente en bas dans le
permien vous allez avoir
une grande diversité d'animaux notamment
des herbivores puisque les herbivores
sont très nombreux dans le registre
fossile plus nombreux que les carnivores
mais dans les herbivores vous allez
avoir d'apt ok phallus par exemple vous
allez avoir liste rose aux russes qui
vont être les deux vraiment les deux
herbivores 2000 en aidant les carnivores
vous allez avoir les gorgones obtient et
puis ensuite arrive la limite par l'unfp
trias et là d'un seul coup y'a plus rien
d'autre que les listes rose aux russes
voilà
mais il y en a en abondance il n'y a pas
de si vous voulez il ya des espèces qui
s'éteignent mais en matière de
d'abondance de biomasse il ne se passe
rien voilà et c'est ça que je veux vous
dire c'est une extinction de masse ça
n'a de valeur que celle qu'on lui donne
à savoir que si vous parlez d'extinction
en termes de biomasse sur le terrain
quand vous regardez il ne s'est rien
passé à la limite permise trias en tout
cas pas sur le
pad en milieu terrestre peut-être en
milieu marin mais je suis pas expert du
milieu marin mais en milieu terrestre il
n'y a pas de perte de biomasse donc ce
qu'on va regarder c'est la diversité et
cette diversité on va la regarder
d'abord le premier réflexe c'est de la
regarder en nombre d'espèces donc en
nombre d'espèces là effectivement on
adapte aux quais phallus plus lisse trop
aux russes qui sont dominants puis on
passa juste liste rose aux russes puis
après on repasse alice trop bistrot
zaurus plus de nouveaux arbitres or
comme pro colophon par exemple et de
nouveaux carnivores donc qui vont
remplacer les gorgones obtient ce
nouveau carnivores et andé archosaures
donc on aa renouveau de la faune avec un
genre de goulets d'étranglement en fait
de biodiversité où on retrouve plus que
des listes rose aux russes donc en
termes de diversité on va être tentés de
regarder d'abord les espèces le problème
des espèces bas c'est qu'elles sont très
très subjective ce que les
paléontologues vous connaissez les
débats éternelle pour savoir combien il
ya un espèce par exemple de tyrannosaure
voilà est-ce que tarbes aux eaux russes
est un tyrannosaurus est-ce que nanou
tyrannus est un tyrannosaurus bref tout
ça taxonomique mans c'est hyper débattu
surtout au niveau de l'espèce dont déjà
on va se contenter de genre déjà les
genres c'est tyrannosaurus et de
l'espèce cerexhe homos c'est le genre
sapiens ces espèces ont déjà pour
essayer de s'affranchir un peu de ses
billets taxonomique on va essayer de
regarder plutôt la taxonomie des
taxonomies au niveau générique qui est
beaucoup moins débattue parce que ce que
pour reprendre l'exemple de liste rose
aux russes si vous aviez fait si vous
aviez regardé l'extinction de masse à la
limite permise trias bah pareil vous
aurez vous auriez pas vu du tout de
perte de biodiversité
parce que la limite permise trias il y
avait 21 une espèce de liste rose aux
riches donc en fait vous auriez eu le
même nombre d'espèces avant qu après
l'extinction de masse c'est juste que
ben il y avait une sur une
sur-représentation taxe youn taxonomique
de liste rose aux russes qui depuis a
été révisé maintenant on a plus que deux
espèces de liste rose au risque dans le
trias ce qui est quand même
ce qui est quand même un peu plus
raisonnable mais voilà si vous aviez
regardé le nombre d'espèces juste
quantifier le nombre d'espèces vous
auriez prévu d'extinction une fois plus
si vous n'aviez regarder le nombre
d'espèces avant 2001 donc maintenant
après 2001 qu'est ce qu'on a on a un
certain nombre d'espèces dans le permien
on a une espèce de liste rose aux russes
pendant la limite permise trias et on a
deux espèces de liste rose russe après
le truc c'est que si vous regardez aussi
que la biodiversité de liste rose aux
russes ben évidemment vous pourriez être
tenté de dire bon il ya quand même pas
mal d'espèces de liste rose aux russes
alors est ce que c'est vraiment une
extinction c'est pour ça que justement
on regarde le niveau générique c'est
parce que tout
même si on considère qu'il y avait un
telle une espèce de liste rose aux
russes basset vas tu es une espèce de
l'histoire russe ça reste tout délit
strauss donc elles sont pas si diverse
que ça au final
donc oui encore une fois
au niveau je vais répéter je vais
récapituler à chaque fois
au niveau biomasse il se passe rien
au niveau
spécifique avant 2001 vous n'auriez rien
vu mais maintenant que le genre liste
rose au russe a été révisé sa taxonomie
éclaircies maintenant vous pourriez voir
une extinction mais pour voir une
extinction faut regarder la taxonomie la
diversité taxonomique au niveau
générique est même arrivé là vous avez
encore un nouveau problème
vous avez encore un nouveau problème qui
se pose à vous c'est que quand vous avez
effectivement de nouvelles espèces qui
apparaissent après votre extinction donc
ici dans le karoo après l'extinction
permien trias vous avez par exemple via
les eaux russes qui apparaît
gars les eaux russes c'est un 7-1
synodaux honte qui ressemble beaucoup à
trie naxos dans ce que trinec sedan il
apparaît vraiment après la limite
permise trias il n'apparaît pas il
apparaît bien après la limite permise
trias il n'apparaît pas immédiatement
après il ya les eaux russes il apparaît
plus immédiatement après la limite
permise trias
et bien ce gars les eaux russes
ce gars les eaux russes il a forcément
des ancêtres et c'est pareil pour les
archosaures les archosaures apparaissent
pile à la limite enfin les arts cause
aux réformes apparaissent pile à la
limite permise trias
mais ça veut quand même dire qu'ils
avaient des ancêtres avant
votre protérozoïque us en afrique du sud
et votre arc aux eaux russes en russie
ils apparaissent à la limite par la
triade certes mais il fallait bien
qu'ils aient des ancêtres avant donc
vous allez inclure à nouveau concept à
votre votre compréhension de la limite
enfin votre compréhension des
extinctions de masse qui est le concept
de ligne et fantômes c'est à dire qu'il
y a des
il ya forcément des choses qu'on ne sait
pas et qui se sont passées avant votre
extinction de masse
arco au russe n'est pas sortie de nulle
part il avait des ancêtres et même si on
en a pas les fossiles ils font en compte
il faut prendre en compte le fait que
ses ancêtres existe
et ça c'est et ça ça ça fout en l'air
tous vos calculs parce que si vous aviez
dans votre idée là de dire bah c'est pas
compliqué une extinction de masse
regardez on prend la section
stratigraphique qui est là derrière en
bas on compte combien d'espèces dans la
limite voilà dans l'extinction de masse
on compte combien il ya des espèces est
au dessus de l'année de la limite on
compte combien d'espèces bon bah déjà je
vous ai dit au niveau de l'espèce ça
marche pas bon vous raconter les gens en
bas on compte combien il ya de gens au
milieu en coupant dans l'extinction en
compte combien d'or et en euros compte
combien de genre normalement on devrait
voir plein de genres pas de gens pas
beaucoup de gens et plein de genre de
nouveau et pouf ça fait une extinction
oui mais non ben oui mais non ce que
vaut genre ils ont forcément des
ancêtres donc les genres qui
apparaissent après l'extinction ils ont
forcément des ancêtres avant
l'extinction et ses ancêtres pour les
inclure dans votre compréhension de
l'extinction de masse vous pouvez pas
juste les ignorer sous prétexte qu'ils
sont pas là que vous les voyez pas
l'absence de preuve n'est pas preuve
d'absence
donc donc donc eh bah ça veut ça vous
rajoute du coût de la biodiversité dans
votre extinction de masse c'est à dire
que de faut admettre que les ancêtres de
ces des trucs qui existe après
l'extinction de masse devaient exister
pendant l'extinction de masse
et là ça va demander de pouvoir
reconstituer des données que vous n'avez
pas et ça va de vous demander de créer
des modèles c'est là que les modèles
interviennent et c'est là où comme je
vous disais condamine ils ont utilisé un
certain type de modèle et ceux d'avant
il avait utilisé un autre type de modèle
c'est pour ça que vous avez besoin des
modèles et puis après vous avez besoin
aussi et ses modèles ils vont se baser
alors généralement c'est des modèles qui
sont basés sur la spéciation c'est à
dire les événements de kladno génèse
dans un arbre phylogénétique ça va vous
permettre de reconstituer en fait les
lignes et fantômes
c'est assez compliqué mais il n'y a pas
besoin de comprendre ça pour comprendre
que en fait on ne sait pas ce qui s'est
passé à la fin du règne des dinosaures
alors on a cette météorite on sait
qu'elle est tombée et on suppose que
quand elle est tombée ça déjà tuer pas
mal de trucs quand elle s'est cassé la
gueule et ça a probablement déclenché
une série d'événements cataclysmiques
qui à l'échelle des temps géologiques et
très courte donc on parle d'un déclin
rapide
rapide à l'échelle des temps géologiques
parce qu'à l'échelle des temps d aller
celle des dinosaures ça a dû être
incroyablement long et douloureux
donc ça aussi c'est une question
d'échelle de dire que le déclin a été
lent ou pas
aussi débat table mais quoi qu'il en
soit laissons de côté ces considérations
purement technique il faut bien
comprendre aussi que la quantité des
données est extrêmement limité depuis
tout à l'heure je vous parle de la
limite permise trias mais en réalité la
limite permise trias en environnement
terrestre on ne l'a que en afrique du
sud et la limite la limite crétacé
tertiaire en environnement terrestre et
ben à part en amérique du nord et un peu
en asie
voilà à quoi donc a pas beaucoup de
limite crétacé tertiaire et quand en
plus on se contente que du milieu
terrestre puisque les dinosaures non
aviens étaient des animaux
essentiellement terrestre spinosaurus
n'existait déjà plus à l'époque donc
c'est pas la peine de me sortir dans les
commentaires
on a on a ce problème que ben on n'a pas
beaucoup de données pour alimenter notre
modèle donc déjà notre modèle il va
prendre il va il va simplifier les
choses parce que c'est le principe du
modèle c'est de simplifier les choses
pour les rendre intelligibles et en plus
ce modèle bas il va falloir lui rentré
des données ces données elles sont
essentiellement nord américaine
parce qu'il a pas beaucoup d'autres
endroits où on a des bonnes limite
crétacé tertiaire donc ces données
essentiellement dans american et avec
condamine du coup il ya aussi beaucoup
de données eurasiatique qui ont été
inclus dans le modèle de condamine
elles sont
elles sont ce qu'elles sont quoi c'est à
dire très limité extrêmement limité en
plus condamine dans leur cas ils ont
vraiment comme ils ont voulu des données
très propre ils ont vraiment utiliser
des groupes qui était très bien connu et
du coup ils ont que des gros animaux les
adh roseaux rider les ceratops hier les
tyrannosaures idées les plus petits
animaux qu'ils ont ce sont les drom et
aux or je crois en même temps vous
pourriez inclure des trucs comme les
ornithologues me dl et après vous
pourriez augmenter le jeu de données en
incluant des ornithologues idées en
incluant des ce et palaiseau vie raptor
idées etc le problème c'est qu'ils ont
un registre fossile pendant le
maastricht ya donc le vraiment la toute
fin de l'extinction
de l'extinction
crétacé-tertiaire enfin toute fin du
crétacé pardon donc pendant le
maastricht un leur registre fossile il
est il est moisi quoi il est pas
terrible il est pas terrible et du coup
qu'est ce que ça fait votre modèle pour
y inclure les sauropodomorphes les
sauropodes puisque on en parlait tout à
l'heure mais les sauropodes séparer leur
registre fossile sur le mas très chiant
il est pas terrible terrible non plus il
est pas mal n'allait pas si mauvais que
ça mais il est pas terrible terrible
essaie de couvrir un peu le vent je
pense que je vais aller me remettre un
peu à l'abri du vent
donc qu'est-ce qu'on en fait de ces gens
là bas on va les exclure parce que
autrement si vous avez un registre
fossile qui est très bon en campagne et
qui ensuite est très mauvais au mas très
chiant ben vous avez forcément conclure
un des cas qui est lent vous biaisée de
base votre échantillonnage pour
reconstruire un déclin relativement lent
donc il faut il faut faire attention à
tout ça
et mai et il faut pas perdre de vue que
c'est des données qui viennent
essentiellement de l'hémisphère nord est
ici l'hémisphère sud on n'a pas beaucoup
d'affleurements ils n'ont pas été
beaucoup exploré mais voilà vous pouvez
pas juste tirer des conclusions hâtives
sur des données qui sont aussi biaisés
enfin vouloir affirmer que les
dinosaures se sont éteints après allant
des classes est à peu près aussi absurde
que de dire qu'ils se sont éteint
subitement on en a aucune idée
on n'en a aucune idée et comme je les
dis tout dépend de comment vous
quantifier une extinction de masse c'est
à dire que si vous parlez en événements
de kladno génèse comme le font les
modèles qui sont généralement employés
si vous parlez simplement nombre de
genres si vous parlez simplement nombre
d'espèces ou si vous parlez simplement
en biomasse et bien vous allez avoir des
conclusions qui seront à chaque fois
différente
quand je regarde là parce que vient de
voir regarder un bon moyen de finir la
vidéo c'est alors que je marchais
alors que je marchais au regard des
menaces
jolie petite hausse dans un gros bloc
que vous voyez là j'ai l'impression que
ça aussi ça la langue de l'os je ne sais
pas ce que c'est mais du coup je sens
que ça va me maintenir occupé pendant un
petit moment
voilà donc c'était c'était julien en
direct en gros différé on va dire plus
du quart ou à la frontière du lesotho où
on cherche des dinosaures et voilà ne
surtout voilà n'oubliez pas que la
science se construit autour du consensus
et pas autour des opinions voilà c'est
sûr c'est surtout ça le gros message
c'est ne partait pas avec l'opinion qui
est que forcément s'il ya une météorite
ça a été une extinction rapide c'est pas
parce qu'il ya eu une météorite que
c'est forcément une extinction rapide il
ya peut-être déjà eu à déclarer une
extinction menthe
une extinction qui était déjà en cours
ou des who du mois il ya eu plusieurs
phases d'extinctions chez les dinosaures
donc il y avait on était peut-être sur
une phase de transition on va dire est
que cette phase de transition s'est vu
brutalement interrompue par la chute
d'un gros caillou donc là n'exclut pas
l'autre voilà c'est juste ça l'idée
c'est juste ça l'idée évidemment et
évidemment du coup démontrer si un jour
cela était possible qu'il y a eu un lent
déclin des dinosaures ne veut pas dire
qu'il n'ya pas eu une météo la météorite
la voilà enfin le cratère ont là et on a
même de la poussière de météorites de
ben
voilà et bien très bientôt j'espère que
j'espère que j'ai été relativement clair
malgré le fait que c'est un peu
improvisée et on se revoit très
prochainement pour une nouvelle vidéo
salut